make no mistake Irma still presents
dangers this morning the City of
Jacksonville is under a flash flood
emergency at this hour the st. John
River which runs through the city is
overflowing its banks city officials say
they're handling a 1 911 minutes and
conditions will only get worse tareka
Duncan is driving right now along the
coast in Atlantic Beach just outside
Jacksonville and she's taking a look at
the initial damage tarika yeah we are in
Atlantic Beach we saw that a lot of the
flooding was happening near the beach
but wanted to get out near the
neighborhoods to show you what it looks
like and we've seen a lot of downed
trees some power lines electrical crews
out here probably trying to restore some
of that power we're here on the corner
of Seminole and Paul Avenue and if you
just look down there you can see the
amount of flooding this is because we're
near a creek you can also see what
appears to be a tree leaning I'm not
sure if it's actually on a home but
we're gonna keep riding just so you can
get a sense of what it's looking like
and some of the neighborhoods outside of
the beach area where we were but it is
still very windy a lot of these palm
trees have come down a lot of the homes
that are boarded up did so for good
reason because they knew that these
winds were going to be as powerful as
they are we see some people outside
right now maybe we can just get a sense
of what they're dealing with
really quickly good morning we're from
CBS News did you guys get a lot of
damage or you're pretty much okay pretty
much okay from these gentlemen right
here but again if you look down this
road there are tree bushes and limbs
down when we were on the main
thoroughfare the street lights are out
there were police on the streets trying
to make sure I believe to keep people
off the roads again electrical crews out
here because a lot of downed trees and a
lot of debris we haven't seen any
significant damage as if up here we go
we got a tree right here that's down I'm
not sure if Jake will be able to get
that through the window but we see a lot
of these split trees these smaller trees
we're gonna keep riding down and then
just kind of go out to the left
to the window so you can see some more
of the the damage but more debris than
anything we're still waiting to hear
back from the mayor to see where the
worst of it is again we're just getting
out here but we can even tell you from
our hotel that pieces of the roof we're
starting to rip off we saw street signs
flying in the air and it is dangerous
it's not necessarily what you want to be
out in at this time but we'll of course
continue to keep you posted on what the
conditions are looking like oh he we
have a downed tree right here at the
window but this is again we're just
getting a look at it for the first time
so this is what it's looking like here
in Atlantic Beach Jeff drinka thanks
very much